Aviation is essential to the European
economy the sector employs two million
people and generates 110 billion euros a
year
it also helps boost Europe's global
presence by driving trade and tourism
but none of this should be taken for
granted the sector faces a growing
number of challenges and fierce global
competition that's why the European
Commission is proposing a new aviation
strategy to keep Europe flying high
negotiating new aviation agreements with
key countries and regions will open up
new markets and create business
opportunities for European companies
citizens will benefit from more flights
new routes and cheaper prices
European air traffic is expected to
increase by 50% by 2035 Europe needs to
plan ahead to accommodate these new
flights the alternative is that
congestion will cause delays and
superfluous co2 emissions and Europe
will lose out on billions of revenues
and thousands of jobs
European Aviation has some of the
highest standards in the world be it for
safety and security Environmental
Protection social issues and passenger
rights but maintaining this leadership
means adapting continuously for instance
we want to reduce the burden of security
controls at airports through the use of
new technologies
keeping Europe at the forefront of
innovation today is the best way to
create the jobs of tomorrow
drones offer tremendous new
opportunities and we must unleash their
full economic potential that's why the
Commission is proposing a framework to
ensure legal certainty for investors and
safety
the goal of the aviation strategy is to
strengthen the entire EU Air Transport
value Network Europe must be a leading
player in international aviation and a
global model for sustainable aviation
with a high level of services and
ambitious standards we want all
Europeans to enjoy more routes at lower
prices and with the highest standards
worldwide so fasten your seat belts
you